so i have this series on my channel
called code review pretty simple concept
people send me code
and i review it it's more of like a fun
kind of let's take a look at some code
and i'll give my
opinion kind of thing now last time i
did this someone sent him their
university assignment i'll have that
video linked up
there and this was like such a
interesting
university assignment to say the least
that i mentioned that maybe i should
just
rewrite it and just do it my way and of
course
everyone wanted that so here i am
sitting down to do a university
assignment in
i think it's been at least five years
since i've done any
university assignments so the plan is
pretty simple i have the
assignment here in front of me i've kind
of taken it and rewritten it basically
paraphrased it because i don't want to
give away the identity of the university
or anything like that
and we are going to give ourselves like
i don't know this shouldn't really
shouldn't take longer than like an hour
but i'm going to basically go through
this talk about the requirements and
then
implement this as best as i can now a
fair warning
what i'm looking at is a real second
year
university assignment i think the unit
subject is called something like
like data algorithms and patterns or
something like that
this is the exact same assignment that
we looked at last time we did a code
review
like this is this is it we're going to
be doing that exact one
the reason why i'm being so specific
about this is because this is a
in my opinion quite an odd university
assignment but hey it's a
real university assignment that someone
actually did and sent in the code for
so that's i'm just i'm gonna do that
what i haven't done is like hand-picked
the best university assignment
i could find the one that would maybe
demonstrate the most value to you
or would be easiest for me to do i'm
just doing the one that we looked at and
i
i never planned to do this assignment
when i did that code review so just a
fair warning
this is this is going this is about to
get interesting so before we take a look
at all of these requirements i want to
mention that this video
is sponsored by skillshare so for those
of you who don't know skillshare is an
amazing online learning community where
millions of creative and curious people
from all around the world
come together to learn new skills
it's honestly in my opinion one of the
best skill sharing
platforms on the internet i mean it's
literally called skillshare they've got
so many classes on pretty much any topic
you could think of
anything from creative topics such as
like videography photography
editing illustration all the way over to
like
business and marketing and productivity
they've also got excellent courses on
how to make youtube videos i really like
this one by
mkbhd as a c plus plus programmer i am
pretty much all about
efficiency and i think skillshare does
an excellent job at that
skillshare's videos are really well made
and they're really kind of
well timed they're like these bite-sized
chunks that you can just watch when you
have a spare five minutes you don't have
to wait till the end of the day and
allocate like an hour or two to just
spend on this thing you can just consume
it kind of on the go coming in at just
under ten dollars a month for an annual
subscription i think skillshare is
fantastic value
but also the first 1 000 people who
click the link in the description below
will receive a one month free trial a
one month free trial of skillshare
premium
is plenty of time to explore the
platform see what they've got and see
what courses you like so go ahead and
click that link in the description below
check out skillshare premium see what
they have to offer
thank you again to skillshare for
sponsoring this video now this
university assignment let's take a look
at the requirements and then we'll kind
of talk about our strategy for
implementing this okay so i just spent a
little bit of time going through the
actual assignment requirements that
whole kind of sheet and then rearranging
them into this kind of dot point format
that we can take a look at together so
the first thing is
this time is gonna be marked
automatically so it's gonna be put
through like a bunch of test cases
as we'll see in a minute failure to
follow this guideline will result in
zero so
they're pretty serious about these
requirements exactly one file
main.cpp no design documents need to be
submitted
and the task is basically to implement a
very specific hash table
so this hash table as i mentioned in the
code review video that we did last time
it's not exactly a hash table even i
mean
you can't just put in a certain key and
then expect to get a value out
the key that you put in it's more of a
hash set
really and i mean the hash set is kind
of pushing it
but basically all it is is a storage
of 26 english words as we'll see in a
minute
and the the word can either be in there
in this data structure or it cannot so
there is no kind of
associative array i can't you know
put in a word and get another word out
that's
what a hash table would be so i mean it
does say it's a very specific hash table
but
i think that one thing we can take away
from this assignment and assignments
like this assignment is that
it is in fact very specific it's unlike
anything that i've actually seen
in the real world which first of all
does kind of
uh you know kind of brings up the point
of is this even useful
but i think in a way it is because this
assignment is a good example of
getting getting you to actually follow
requirements
because it needs to be done exactly in
this way so this very specific hash
table what is it keys are lowercase
english words
so like apple for example length of a
key is at most
10 so like words under 10 characters
the hash function is and this is a quote
simply using the last character
example the hash of apple is e so if we
put in a word like apple
the hash is in fact e which means that
obviously if there's
i don't know apple and orange those are
two words that end in e
there will be a collision but of course
we can deal with collisions as we'll
find out in a minute the hash table
contains exactly 26 slots
a2z by the way if you're following along
with this at home try and write down
these requirements and
implement this for yourself i think
it'll be a good exercise and then we can
compare our solutions in the end you
won't
need more because of course this is
designed to just go through the test
cases
it's marked automatically if it goes
through the test cases you win
that's not to say we should maybe hack
this and just produce something that
isn't even a hash table but
you know that is that is possible table
slots have three different statuses
never used tombstone or occupied so the
fact that these are here and in quotes
to me basically says that okay so we
have 26 slots
they have to be strings they have to be
either never used tombstone or occupied
because
i mean i guess fundamentally they don't
need to be strings
but it seems to imply that they should
be strings
table starts with never used um
so basically i guess in the beginning we
initialized 26 slots all we've never
used
searching works as follows so given a
key take its last character as the hash
value
so if we enter a key like apple then e
is in fact the uh
the last character first try the
corresponding table slot so each
letter in the english alphabet a through
z
has a table slot so we could basically
have an array where it's like
from 0 to 25 and then we just need some
kind of
conversion function to convert from the
letter into the table slot
i mean it's just really just we could
use it as an index if the key is there
you found it if it's never used it
doesn't exist so if we put an apple and
we get back never used
it never existed if the key is occupied
or tombstone
then move to the next slot so if we're
trying to look for apple and we get
occupied and it's not apple
or we get tombstone then we try and move
to the next slot and we may need to like
wrap the table so if we're at slot 25
we'll go back to zero
keep trying until key is found or we're
certain it doesn't exist
so so at worst this is just going to
search
the entire table basically i mean it's
kind of unlikely because if we run
into never used then it doesn't exist so
unless the table is literally full
and we don't have that key we're not
going to search everything
keep trying until key is found always
certain it doesn't exist yet insertion
works as follows so first perform
search to see if the key exists if it
does
then do nothing take the take the last
character
of key as hash value so we get if we're
trying to insert apple we take e
if that slot is not occupied put the key
there and occupy the slot if it's
occupied try the next slot until you
find a free slot
so this is the collision kind of
management so what happens is if we
already have apple
in the list i mean i'm even accidentally
calling it a list instead of a hash
table because that's basically what it
is but if we have apple in there already
and we're trying to insert orange they
both end in e we end up in that same
kind of index
but what we do is we just go forward in
index
so we effectively put it into the slot
of the letter
f instead of e now according to these
requirements
if it's occupied try the next slot until
you find a free slot
until you find a free slot so if there
is no free slot
um this will just go infinitely and i'm
pretty sure that's what the assignment
that we looked at
did it's just it just happens to be that
none of the test cases
happen to use more than 26 and i mean
the assignment does say that
we have exactly 26 slots and we won't
you won't need more
so if you won't need more then i guess
this is fine because
it will it should never run into a
problem where it just
can't insert the value because there's
no free slots since at most we have 26
slots and
26 possible inputs deletion works as
follows given a key
search for it to locate its slot if it
doesn't exist
do nothing and if found change to
tombstone so if it
if i it doesn't really say what to do if
so i guess if you run into it never used
then clearly it doesn't exist
tombstone would mean you go to the next
slot because there could have been
another key there
but then also if you get occupied and
it's not the key you're looking for
then you also move to the next slot so i
wonder what would happen if you
try to delete a key
and then you try to delete that same key
again it would probably go through the
whole table
and not find it but then the search
function
keep trying until he's found always
certain it doesn't exist so the search
function needs a way then
to basically terminate if it has in fact
searched
everything and it couldn't find it again
very unlikely because
we will we will run into a never used
unless the hash table is full
so i guess we can ignore that when
program starts init empty hash table so
26 never use slots
okay command line input is 1 through 26
modification
moves separated by spaces so moves are
a word which is the character a followed
by a lower case english word of up to 10
characters so
a apple means insert key apple into hash
table
same with d except d is for delete so
delete apple from hash table is d
apple once input is processed output is
all the slots in the hash table that
have occupied values
separated by spaces ignore invalid
inputs so
if the input is malformed we just ignore
it okay so sample input is
this a apple a orange so we've added
apple and orange
and then we've deleted apple and then
we've added strawberry and we get orange
strawberry which is what you would
expect submit via svn
and then marking done automatically
total markers 10 one for compiling
and then nine marks for nine test cases
and it's also compiled using g
plus plus um with c plus plus 11
optimization two warnings all main.cpp
so obviously we have to provide a
main.cpp as it mentioned above and then
we also have to
uh make sure that we are in fact only
using simple house 11
and that it compiles with g plus plus so
that's obviously the compiler we're
going to use for this assignment the uh
the sun is really creeping up on me you
know i didn't really plan for this to be
this in
depth let me know what you think of this
kind of uh
this this kind of video i was going to
just skim through it in like 10 minutes
but
there's just so much here to unpack so
i'm probably gonna skip the whole
designing this stage i mean the
assignment mentioned we don't need to
submit any kind of design document
and also i think this video is dragging
on long enough so i'm probably just
going to jump into the code and start
programming this
at its core i think it's quite simple it
shouldn't really give us too much
trouble
there's just a few particular cases and
um you know i mean i
i don't really want to change this too
much like
you know it it says table slots have
those kind of never used tombstone or
occupied statuses
i could make that some kind of enum or
an integer or
just like something like that i don't
think i will i'm not really going to be
focusing on performance here i'm just
going to try and implement this
as best i can based on these
requirements and obviously so that it
actually
gives us our output correctly okay so as
we dive into this let's take a little
bit of a look at my
setup for this assignment so i basically
have just made a folder
i've opened up sigwin and then the
reason for this is because i just
found this on my computer and it
happened to have g plus plus kind of in
the path
i didn't really have this in command
prompt so that's why i'm using this just
so that i don't have to like add it to
my path or do anything crazy like that
you can use anything you want because
the only reason to use this terminal at
all
is for the actual compilation now if we
take a look at the university
requirements
they're pretty specific meaning that we
need to use basically this exact
command to compile our code if we don't
do that then there's a possibility
that of course it won't compile like if
our files are not named correctly
or something like that it just won't
compile obviously on the automated
testing and
when you're dealing with automated
testing you need to make sure that
everything works exactly the same way
that it's going to be automatically
tested i don't want to get zero for this
assignment
so we have to use this now instead of
typing this all the time
uh it makes sense to kind of put this
into like a little bit of a batch file
now i don't think that like
we're not going to be the ones running
the command we don't need to write a
file like a script for the server to
execute
or whatever they're going to be running
the command so this is just for us and
we're on windows so i'm just going to
touch a file here called like build.bat
and then inside that build.bat file that
we've just made let's go ahead and drag
it here
and then we can paste in that command
that's all we're doing it's just so that
instead of actually having to run that
command every time
i can just call uh build.bat
like this please help me um
now if it's giving you a permission
denied it's because this is like a kind
of
linux e terminal i guess and so we have
to actually
do a chmod plus x to make it executable
so let's go ahead and do that not
technically required on windows we can
of course just run it normally but to
run it through this it wants that to be
happy
anyway there we go so we don't have a
main.cpp file so let's quickly just
touch that
in here and now we can just drag it in
to our um vs code
over here and we can just edit that
let's just try compiling it i mean
obviously it's not going to really do
anything
oops i touched it again let's go back
and run build.bat
and then i mean we don't have a main
function or anything like that so it's
not going to do anything but obviously
it's sending the right file to the
compiler
so the first thing i always do in these
cases i mean always
is just make sure that my tool chain is
set up correctly especially when
compiling from the command line
so all you have to do for that is
include like i o stream and just try and
print something
so i'm going to go ahead and print hello
like this
and then if we go back to our
sequin over here and try to build up
that you can see that it compiles
and it gives us a main dot out if i run
this main dot out
then we get hello printing and
everything as well now to make this a
little bit easier
what i can do is actually call build bat
and and so double ampersand and then
main dot out
and that way it will compile it and then
run it immediately so this is kind of
nice when we're testing if you don't
want to set up like a whole
thing through vs code because i don't
really care about that to be honest
okay so moving on to the actual code i'm
going to be referring to the assignment
requirements pretty heavily for this
i have them on my other monitor so i'm
not going to show them all time if you
want to look at them you can go back in
the video
but i will highlight certain things so
the first thing that i actually feel
like starting with
is the input processing so we know that
based on what they've told us
the input can either be um like a word
or
d word basically so if i copy and paste
stuff from the
assignment sheet that i made earlier
then you can see we have a apple a
orange and in fact let's go ahead and
copy the sample output
so if we start to take a look at this
input i basically just want to make this
command parsing work why because it's
going to be the foundation for testing
the rest of the application and i like
to iterate
frequently and test pretty much all the
time so how are we going to be able to
pass this input
so we know that we have one character
here a or d that's going to be
basically one of two commands so we
clearly need to determine
uh whether or not the command is to add
or delete
but before we do that we also need to be
able to take in a string
like this and separate it by each space
lots of different ways to do this i
think the most straightforward way that
is also obviously supported in uh
c plus 11 is just to use string stream
honestly
so what this means is that if we wanted
to take a line in which it seems like if
we look at the requirements they're not
actually command line arguments the
sample input is literally
this it's not like you know running the
application
and then passing in everything as
command line arguments so we're not
going to be using those we need to
actually be able to take an
input from scdc in that's how i
interpret it and that's also how the
assignment we looked at during the code
review did it
so because of that let's go ahead and
just basically write our input here
we'll use the getline function to just
get that input line from c in this
obviously gets
our entire line and then what i want to
do is
actually feed this into string stream so
if i go std
string stream ss with that input string
what i can do now is just keep pulling
out tokens from this
so if i write a while loop that
continues
basically as long as that string stream
still has tokens for us to process
we can simply pull out the token uh by
using this kind of
bit shift right operator here so now we
should just
have a list of tokens basically so let's
go ahead and try and print them just to
make sure everything
is working successfully and you can see
we basically have most of our input
parsing sorted
already very easy so i'll save that by
the way we do not need a return
zero that's not really required although
now that i'm thinking about it maybe it
is in c
11 maybe that's a newer feature but um
no actually we would have gotten a
warning especially with warning all so
the main function is special in the fact
that even though it returns int you
don't have to return anything and it
will assume you're returning zero so
let's go ahead and run
our little command once again and we'll
see what we get so okay so it's waiting
for input now
so let's go ahead and copy this input
that we'll be using as a little sample
input for now
i'll paste it in and run it and you can
see we get every
token here on a separate string so that
that's immediately done i mean you can
see how quick that is
really really easy to use um and
no need to like go through every
character look for spaces anything like
that we can just take advantage of this
t
plus plus standard library that was
available to us back in
back in the day back in sleepless 11.
okay so moving on
now let's go with the kind of second
part of the input parsing which is
what do we want like to add an element
in to insert an element or to
remove an element so to do that we just
simply need to
of the like for each token so our token
obviously is going to be like this for
example
for every token we just check the first
character so in other words uh
if that first character of the token so
token 0 is equal to a right and remember
it has to be
in this format has to be uppercase this
has to be lowercase
everything's very much set in stone so
it's really easy for us to do our jobs
here
if token equals a then that's kind of it
else if
so there's no reason for us to check it
again so we can just use an else if
we can go over here and uh check to see
if it's d and so basically this means
that we have an add command
and we have a delete command but then we
have the next kind of stage of this
which is kind of
okay so i've got my add and delete
commands but what string do i send
to that command right because um we
obviously don't want to just take the
token and send it because the token is a
apple we are interested in this so what
is the easiest way
for us to actually uh take this i guess
take this token and just trim
off that first character so a few ways
come to mind
um the simplest one probably using the
standard library is just to use
substring
so if we go ahead and say like sd string
and i guess this is like entry name
um we can just set that to like token
dot
sub string so substitute one and then
that will automatically go to the end of
the string
and starting from the first character so
that's definitely going to work i think
so if we go ahead
and well let's kind of set this up so
we'll do scdc out
and then we'll say add and then i'll
print the actual entry name that we're
trying to add here
notice that i've written this um in
uh let's quickly add that end line in
notice that i've written this
up here i'm not doing it in each if
statement because it applies to both
and if that if if we give an invalid
input then
it doesn't really matter anyway um so
let's go ahead and
go back here and see what we get so i'm
going to go ahead and paste in my input
and then you can see we have add apple
add orange delete apple and add
strawberry
let's for fun put in like some inputs
that um
are just a bit weird so i'll put these
in but maybe the first
uh i know i've ruined something let's
try that again so if i paste
in like this input for example but let's
just archer which is a bit weird oh
thanks for overriding everything but
whatever
then you can see it just simply ignores
cherno it just goes with well actually
add apple still
and then cherno's here ah this is just i
think this is just sigma being weird so
let's go ahead and run that again
um so let's just type in hello a apple
d orange which doesn't exist and then
some random stuff
you can see out of that it only took an
add and delete because those are invalid
commands okay so it ignores all the
other ones which looks like it works
fine
the other way that comes to mind that
isn't really required is we could
just use the constructor of our city
string that takes in like a cons chart
pointer
so in other words if we were to get like
this
character from it basically right um
except set this to be the memory address
of the first character of this which is
this the memory address of this since
it is just a string buffer we can also
do that
um i assume i'm not going to lie that
actually came to mind first
because i'm usually thinking about
memory and stuff like that
but you can see that we get the same
kind of result i would probably leave it
as substring just because it probably
makes more sense
to most people okay brilliant so we've
got the entry names we've got all of the
input parsing done it ignores everything
it's very clean
at least in my opinion so let's go ahead
and talk about the actual hash table now
so the way that i want to write this um
because we have some fair initialization
code that we need to do remember we have
to
fit we have to fill in 26 slots with the
status i've never used
so i'm actually going to write a class
for this um it's not really required
to do this of course you can write this
however you like but i'm i'm kind of
thinking of it as a class
and i want to keep it organized under a
class so what we're going to do is write
a hash table
to be honest the constructor i think is
probably just going to be a default
constructor
and then this is going to contain a
bunch of entries and this entry
structure i'm going to create in a
minute but each entry is going to
contain the actual data that we're
storing as well as the status because
those need to be stored
separately so we're going to go ahead
and i guess i'll just call this
entries and we know we need 26 of them
rather than writing 26
i'm probably going to let's make a
little
uh so i can't use constant expression
const expert because that's not a 6
11 thing so let's go ahead and just make
a static constant
i'll call this size so this is inside
the hash table namespace so clearly
we're referring to the hash table size
and i can just pass in size as long as
it's const g plus plus probably accepts
non-constant
uh like stack allocated array things as
well but whatever we'll leave it as this
so um let's go ahead and create that
entry struct
again i'm going to create this right
within the hash table like this in the
public section
because i we don't need to pollute the
namespace or anything and i don't want
to call it hashtable entry it
fits perfectly inside this class again
i'm just using this as a bit of an
organizational thing
so we have the data which we're storing
and then the status as a string which
feels a little bit
uh a little bit wrong to me to store
status as a string but again we're
following the assignment directly
and it's not really going to make any
difference if we really think about it
if you spell everything right and you're
not going to have like thousands of
string comparisons which isn't going to
happen
okay so anyway we've got this we've got
our 26 entries now
let's go ahead and actually fill out
these commands so the first step that it
actually says by the way
is to initialize everything with never
use which i've actually already done
right so entry creates 26 of these they
get initialized with never used so
technically speaking we should already
have 26 never used entries just by doing
this
we don't need to manually iterate
through everything and to kind of
uh you know demonstrate this i'm going
to write a print function which we need
anyway because the output needs to be
that
and that's basically going to go through
and just output um
all of the entries that we actually have
but for now what i'm going to do
is actually go through every entry and
just print everything mostly for
debugging
so i'll go through all of the size here
and then basically what i'm going to do
is just do scdc out
and then we'll do m entries
m entries i and let's do
let's just print the status of the
entries for now um
and i mean i guess it makes sense to
also do the data when we're debugging
and stuff like that so
let's do data and then um
maybe like some kind of uh
bracket over here parentheses
to actually print the status and uh
obviously the data here as well
so let's go ahead and just run print
basically so i'm going to go ahead and
actually create the
hash table it doesn't really matter
where we do
this um let's just do it like
maybe over here so we'll go ahead and
say hash table
hash table and then um after we pass all
the input i'm just going to go
and do hash table dot print which will
eventually become the print function of
printing it in this format
which is what we uh require so let's go
ahead and run that
um i will paste in my um
my test kind of case and then you can
see that we already end up with
no data in any of them and just 26 never
use slots so everything looks like
it's working pretty well okay so the
next stage
is to add these functions that are going
to add or delete
our entries so we don't actually need
these because i'm just going to call
hashtable
dot add and then i want to pass in the
entry name so we have add and delete
could call this insert but we'll call it
add for a
um and uh let's write these functions so
up over here
void add now we're using okay so i
probably would take this in as some kind
of string view
but since we are using c plus 11 which
doesn't have that i'm just going to take
it as a const reference
so const scd string entry name we'll
call it maybe entry string because it's
not necessarily
a name i might go over here and rename
it as well for consistency
not that any human is going to read this
assignment apparently it's just going to
be all done through
uh an automated testing little program
so
great anyway um so we have uh
add and delete so what is ad going to do
so let's take a look at the requirements
so to add we first need to perform a
search to see if the key exists so what
that means is that we need to look at
this first
so given a key take its last character
is the hash value let's focus on that
first
so what i'm going to do is actually
write a find function
which i guess will return like a boolean
whether or not it actually finds what
we're looking for now if i'm being
really like pedantic about the
organization i guess i would mark this
as private i like to make a separate
private section for
functions versus members by the way
so we'll have a find function that takes
in some kind of entry string and looks
for it
but obviously in order to actually find
it we need to first be able to hash it
so i'll call the hash function get index
because that makes a little bit more
sense to me and i guess what we'll do is
we'll just accept in a string
and we'll get back the index into this
array that it should belong to
so how do we calculate the index well
the hash function remember is just the
last
character of the string so entry string
dot back
gets us the very last character no need
to do something like
entry string entry string dot size -1
you can just use the dot back function
and it will get you
the last character of that entry string
but now how do we map that into an index
here i mean we know that if the
character is a
and it is in fact through um from a to z
a should probably map to like
zero inside here and then z should map
to 25 which
i mean it won't at this case so how do
we write a conversion function
well the way that ascii works obviously
is that every character
actually has like a numeric value and if
we look if we take a look at like ascii
table dot com for example
we know that the lowercase letter a has
a decimal
value of 97. so if we were to
take the last character like a which is
actually just an integer with the value
97
and subtract 97 from it we get 0
which is exactly the spot for it
similarly if we get the second character
b
and we subtract 97 from it is 98
we get 1 which is slot 1 all the way
down to z if we subtract 97 from 122
we will in fact get 25 which is the
correct value
so all we have to do is subtract the
numeric value now that's
really really easy to do there's no need
to like create some weird switch
statement that goes through and like
you know tries to map you know a to 97
it already is that value so all we need
to do
is take entry string dot back which is a
char and subtract
another chart from it like a and that
will subtract 97 from whatever the
character value here
is now of course if we abuse this and
put in
uppercase characters or symbols we will
probably get a crash because it will not
be in the bounds of the array
but that's not what the assignment
requirements state
so that's all we'll do we just have to
return entry string dot back minus a
that is our entire hash function
pretty easy so now that we've done this
uh
hash value key thing find first try the
corresponding table slot if the key is
there we found it
if it's never used it doesn't exist so
we can return false from our find
function
if the key is occupied or tombstone then
move to the next slot
and keep trying until the key is found
always certain it doesn't exist pretty
simple
so all we have to really do is go
through basically every slot
check to see if it's actually is equal
to the string that we're trying to
search for
and then if it is returned true if it's
not and it's
and it's never used return false
otherwise we can obviously return
uh otherwise we just keep going
basically so let's go ahead and
start by probably declaring some kind of
index which is going to be the ideal
index of entry string so we can do that
by just running our get index function
with the entry string and then
we can just write a little while true
loop to make this kind of easy
now it didn't say anything about
terminating after a certain uh
you know after a certain kind of amount
of iterations or if we can't find the
string
because remember we'll never have more
than 26 so it's a little bit you know i
probably wouldn't write this in real
code but
for the assignment it's totally fine so
what we'll do is
uh check every entry so now we're at
this index so we just need to check
entries at that index to see whether or
not
the status here is well let's just go
with never used first so if it's never
used
um and uh it's not equal to what we're
actually
looking for then we know we can just
return false but obviously before we do
that we actually need to
see if this index contains what we are
looking for and we can do that by just
doing m
entries dot index dot data equals that
entry string and if it does then we
found the string and we can return true
even though i'm writing false for some
reason
so there we go return true if it's never
used we return false and then obviously
the last thing to do is actually
increment the index now we can't just
increment it because if it's some
because it needs to be able to wrap
around
so instead we can just set index equal
to index plus one
mod the size of our table basically and
that will
wrap around if it's 25 it'll go back to
zero when we try and add one to it and
then mod it
so that's pretty simple if we somehow
get to the end of this
i mean this will never this is
unreachable code but we'll write it
anyway
return false again i would really make
this terminate after like 26 iterations
but
um whatever so let's go ahead and try
that out i guess
we'll try and find something that has
been oh well i mean we can't do this yet
because we
haven't added anything so the first step
is try is to try
and see if the key exists if we're
inserting
uh if it does do nothing okay otherwise
take the last character of the key as
the hash value obviously we have our get
index
function if that slot is not occupied
put the key there
and occupy the slot if it is occupied
try the next slot
so immediately let's implement the first
stage of that um let's go ahead and just
write a boolean called exists we'll call
find on
entry string so if it if it does already
find it so we're trying to insert
something that exists we can just return
basically from the function
um otherwise let's take a look at uh
where to add it so now i'm thinking like
okay
i mean we've searched this this already
goes through the loop we could write
another function
that basically tries to find the next
available
spot for insertion and i think i will do
that
the other idea that came to mind that we
might use for something else a little
bit later
is actually taking in a parameter that
is our kind of out insertion index and
that way
when we do stumble upon a never use or a
tomb slot just since we're
since we are actually iterating through
this we could just immediately set out
index to that first index but
i think it will probably make more sense
to just write another function
which um is something like find
or something like get insert index or
something like that
so get insert index will find the first
available place where we can in fact
insert
entry string and so what it will do is
again it needs to
see what the ideal index is and now
it's just about seeing what is currently
at that index because if there's nothing
at that index so if it is in fact never
used
then um we will in fact just return this
index
since we can put it in there and in fact
it's not if it's just never used it's
also if it's
uh tombstone because it's that you know
an object has been deleted and the
requirements state that if it's
tombstone or never used
then obviously that's a valid insertion
index otherwise we basically keep going
so in other words if the status is in
fact
uh occupied then we keep going until we
find a suitable index
um so this will return an int instead
um we're obviously returning index
otherwise i don't know we can return
negative one it doesn't matter this is a
wild true loop and
anyway we won't get into that also this
is another really good case for why
string comparisons are just a really
weird idea for this
um you know we have to type this
perfectly otherwise it's not going to
work
and also we are literally just comparing
comparing character by character
to see if these are equal i don't know
why we're doing that comparing an
integer like
viral enum would be obviously a lot
better but
we're doing this this way because i like
pain
okay so now we obviously can scroll back
up here
um and just see what our kind of
insertion insert index i'll call it is
so we'll run
get insert index with entry string that
should give us back a valid index and
then all we have to do
is do m entries insert index we need to
set the data to be our entry string and
then we need to set the status to be
occupied uh and i think that's probably
it for the add function let's go ahead
and test this i'm a little nervous
because
we've written a lot of code there is no
like you know
intellisense or any kind of error
checking inside
this uh text editor so let's go ahead
and just run
that and see if it even compiles okay it
did somehow um
and let's oh well actually i'm not
adding anything am i i know i am
so let's see because it will in fact
print it so let's copy our example case
and see
what happens obviously delete doesn't
really work yet
okay so um what do we have we have apple
occupied at slot what is a zero one two
three
four so a b c d e and it does in fact
end with e
that's occupied orange is occupied at
the next available slot because it also
ends with e remember i mentioned it
would take the
f slot and then strawberry is occupied
at the y slot because this is obviously
z
so looks pretty good obviously deleting
doesn't work but
i think we were able to validly kind of
validly i don't know if that's a word
um we were able to insert properly all
of our kind of elements that we try to
let's make delete work so what does
delete do
um so delete basically does uh something
similar to
this right i mean it tries to
find whether or not this entry string
exists if it doesn't exist then we
return because there's nothing to delete
but otherwise we need to actually like
find the index
of that actual entry right so this is
where i am actually going to modify the
find function so the find function
returns true or false
i could get it to return an index and
then we could check to see if the index
is negative one
which means it didn't find it something
like that but what i'll do is instead
i'll take in an integer by reference
which is going to be out index right i'm
just i'm labeling it as
out so we know it's an output parameter
but um basically what this is going to
be
is in the case of the fact that it does
in fact find what we're looking for
it's going to set the out index to be
whatever
index that happened to be at so now it
gives us a little bit more information
it doesn't just
tell us whether or not the entry string
exists it tells us
where it exists and that's perfect for a
function labeled find
so now what we can do and that's really
i think all we need to do because this
returns false we don't care about that
so if we go back up here we'll have to
add it into here even though it's unused
so i could um you know just label this
as index or even
unused if i wanted to by the way i could
make this a pointer
and that way it's null by default and if
it's not by default you don't have to
use it that way you know what i've
already shown you guys how to do it this
way i might as well show you the other
way
so the other way would be if we make
this a pointer
instead set it to null pointer as a
default parameter
and then what we could do is uh set
uh out index to index if it's actually
valid so if it's not null
we'll set out index to index like so
dereferencing and copying the value into
that output parameter and then
um over here that means we can still
uh for the for this case we can call it
with no parameter
but then for this case we can in fact
make an integer
called index um and then pass that in
like so so let's go ahead and compile
that and make sure that works
um okay it does i'm not gonna lie i was
slightly scared that default parameters
weren't supported in cpus 11 for some
reason
i think i'm thinking of like c plus plus
98 or something uh
way older than c plus 11 or c plus zero
three um anyway so
delete um so if it doesn't exist for
return otherwise we've already got the
index of deleting it so what do we do
well really all we need to do is mark
for that particular index the status
as tombstone now we could clear the data
it doesn't really tell us that we have
to and obviously if it's tombstone when
we write our print function properly
it's not going to print it it's only
going to print occupied
slots so we don't really need to worry
about wasting time
changing the data that's kind of it the
one thing i will do to these two
functions is i'm going to
change the if statements because at the
moment i mean we have a return here and
we also return obviously when we get to
the end of the function
multiple function returns can be a
little bit confusing if this was a huge
function i would definitely leave this
here because i don't like to put
massive uh you know bodies of like if
statements and stuff like that
but for this because it's only three
lines of code and here it's even
it's even shorter it's just one line of
code what i'll do is i'll say
if not exists right then we can add it
by just basically uh putting this inside
the if statement like so and then here
if it does exist let's just delete it
like that so this makes it a little bit
more clear
and that way we know where we exit the
function it's going to be in the same
place
i think that is possibly it so
let's take a look at this again um i
can't believe we're getting no compile
errors i mean i'm just
writing this and no errors look at that
so where's our example cases
uh here they are um
paste okay so we didn't crash which is
nice
um okay so apple has been set to
tombstone right because we added apple
we added orange we deleted apple
and then we added strawberry so apple
has in fact been changed to tombstone
now here's another test actually
tombstone should be a valid parameter to
use so what happens if i do apple orange
and then let's add something else
grape is also a fruit that
ends in an e so let's go back and uh
try and add that in because it should
occupy that slot actually
so that that'll be a nice little test um
i know i'm compiling it every time i run
it but
it's okay it's fast um all right so
there we go so apple okay apple
tombstone and then grape
actually goes to this occupied slot so
i'm not sure why it didn't actually use
this let's go back to the code and see
maybe why
so get insert index is in fact supposed
to check to see if
tombstone is a thing so
that is uh very interesting
oh never mind it's because i'm adding
the grape before i delete the apple so
that's
that's fantastic so let's go ahead and
make sure we add this after we delete
the apple
and we'll try that out paste this
in and there you go so now grape is in
apple's
slot basically so i think that's kind of
it now the last thing is obviously to
make sure that this is um
formatted in the right way because
that's our our expected output i'll get
rid of this
and then so to do that we'll basically
just go through and iterate
over all of our outputs wherever that
happens here we go in the print
function except instead of printing uh
you know the status which we kind of use
only for debugging
i'm going to go ahead and let's add a
body to this if statement i'm going to
go ahead and just check to see if the
status
is occupied because if it is occupied uh
then we
uh actually what am i doing status
equals occupied
then um then we're going to go ahead and
print the data otherwise we're not so we
don't want to print it on a separate
line we actually want to print it along
with like a space
so i will add that in and then i guess
we'll print a separate line
at the end so it's a little neater okay
that i believe is it
so let's go ahead and run this i'll
paste in my data which is
gone let's go ahead and find it again
paste it in and we get a whole bunch of
nothing
and that of course is because this
should be
out here not after every iteration
just because the for loop didn't have a
body before this let's go ahead
try that again paste that in orange
strawberry
that is in fact our expected output
so i believe we have finished this
assignment about 100 lines of code
uh pretty pretty quick to do i think
this code is a lot cleaner than
the code that we obviously reviewed last
time and hopefully
you learned a thing or two by watching
me do this assignment
now before we actually claim that we've
done it
let's take a look at the test cases
because i also have access to those
so these over here are the actual test
cases that were
uh given to everyone doing the
assignment
first of all i mean you can i don't want
to like roll the ball
we'll say on on anyone here but like the
effort that has gone into this
assignment is so little i mean there's
just random characters like one of these
has actual words
anyway so let's go ahead and uh i mean
i'm not gonna do all of these let's go
ahead and maybe
do this one and see if we get the
expected output
so let's go ahead and um actually these
might have been the actual test cases
because it says your output
so this is this is cool so let's go
ahead and grab this test case over here
we'll go ahead and run this and we'll
paste in
the uh input and the output is banana
orange tomato
which is in fact correct let's try this
like crazy long one here um we'll go
ahead and clear this
and run main dot out
paste enter now i'm not going to compare
this manually so i'll just go ahead and
copy this
and see if we can find it within here
and in fact it does show up in defined
results so we know that it is in fact
the correct string and uh let's go this
has a bunch of deletions let's go ahead
and
try this one and we'll call it a day so
main dot out right click paste enter
then we get a
uh yeah like five a's or six a's
and then this okay cool so that is in
fact a
wrap so actually one thing i forgot to
mention was that students were given
three weeks to complete this assignment
i just uh
wanted to throw that in there let's go
ahead and clean this up a little bit
i will leave a link to this in the
description below in case you guys want
to take a look at this if you have any
questions about this implementation
or you want to or you have some
suggestions as to how to make it better
please let me know of course share all
of that in the comment section below
but otherwise i think we managed to do a
pretty good job so a couple things that
i
noticed while editing this actually is
um i mean for a lot of these functions i
could have definitely
made them const it's a little thing but
it's usually something that i like to do
i just forgot to do it um so obviously
these don't actually modify the state so
it's
fine to kind of make them um const
and then the other thing was if we're
really being kind of pedantic and we
should be
to be honest because it is automated
testing this print function
uh prints our values but it adds a space
after every single value that it prints
meaning that
if we did have something like this um
this does have a space after it so the
expected output
doesn't have a space after it but it
looks like um
the person who did this uh code review
actually did have a space after it like
we did
and i guess um i mean they got i think
10 out of 10 or something like that for
it
so clearly that's fine the automated
testing ignores spaces i guess
but if we were really being like super
uh you know serious about these
requirements we wouldn't want that space
to be printed now unfortunately this
isn't quite as straightforward as it
seems because we can't just do something
like
if i less than like size -1 then print a
space because we're not iterating
through all of the elements necessarily
isn't we're not printing all of the
elements necessarily
i you know i less than that might not
have an occupied slot which means that
well you know we'll always print that
space so to be honest the
simplest kind of logical thing that i
can think of is to actually do the space
first that way we'll never have a
trailing space but then the question
obviously is whether or not we do it for
the first iteration
right and so what we can easily do is
just have a little first thing where
basically
if it is not the first element then
we will do a
then we will do a c out with a space uh
and then
i guess we can we can just set first to
true here all the time
except let's like set this to false
because that'll be correct so
then basically what we have here is uh a
little boolean
called true that we basically uh we we
won't
actually mark it as false until we run
through this for the first time then
we'll just keep setting it to false
which is fine
but the idea is that we only do this we
don't do this for the first time that we
print this
um so obviously we get rid of it here
right so we add a leading space
if it's not our first element that we're
printing and that way we'll never have a
trailing space to deal
with so if we go back over here let's uh
compile this and run it and let's try
this input because i don't think we
tried this one
so if i paste this in i mean i guess
it'll be hard to see if we actually have
a trailing space
but you can i guess you can see over
here that um it doesn't look like
there's a trailing space
and this of course should be the correct
output
and you can see that it is okay so i
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please don't forget to hit the like
button below let me know what you
thought of this
kind of uh video i mean it's not
something i've
really ever done before so i'm
definitely interested in your feedback
hopefully this was helpful to you guys
if you have any criticisms for my code
feel free to point them out in the
comment section below and have like a
discussion with everyone
if you have any particular university
assignments or other kind of tasks that
you may have done that you found
interesting and you'd like me to either
review them or maybe even
take a crack at implementing them then
send an email to
chinareview gmail.com the email address
will be in the description below and
i will take a look at hopefully some
interesting content like this
in the future but anyway thank you guys
for watching don't forget that you can
check out the link in the description
below to get your free trial of
skillshare premium
and i will see you guys next time
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you